he's become the face of Hong Kong's
pro-democracy movement on Mondays
student Joshua Wong was released from
prison and walked straight into a media
scrum where he called for the city's
leader carried Lam to quit Hong Kong
people we will not keep stylists under
the suppression of President Xi and the
chief executive Carolyn Carolyn
otherwise I believe in the next few
weeks before the 22 anniversary Hong
Kong transfer of sovereignty Hong Kong
people not only 1 million or 2 million
people will come and join our fight
until they get back our basic human
rights and freedom ones relief comes
after organizers claim as many as 2
million people took to the streets of
Hong Kong on Sunday they were protesting
about a controversial bill which would
allow extradition to mainland China
under mounting pressure Lam who's backed
by Beijing had already promised to
postpone the law but that wasn't enough
to quell the anger I'm here to condemn
the police violence against us it's
unacceptable that the police define our
demonstration last Wednesday as a riot
lamb even justifies the police violence
as righteous measures that's why I'm
here to urge her to step down for a few
hours on Monday morning demonstrators
continued to block a road leading to
government buildings there concerns over
Beijing's tightening grip on the former
British colony have not gone away many
now see this is a battle for Hong Kong
Seoul okay let's get the very latest
and now from Matias Bollinger he's in
Hong Kong for us this morning
good morning to you Matias Porto
protesters out again today very angry we
saw in that report against excessive
force what's happening right now where
you are
the area you see behind me is the
petition area of the Legislative Council
that's exactly the area the police say
protesters had tried to enter which
triggered the police reaction this this
massive use of tear gas and rubber
bullets to clear the space now the
protesters are here the police
is has retreated so this is a clear
first victory for the protesters and we
might be in for another long occupation
of downtown Hong Kong that was our
correspondent Matias building uh talking
to me earlier DWS honks when Lee is with
us in the studio now to talk more about
this good morning to you we just saw the
protesters there they're not moving
there at the petition site there where
the government sits the extradition
bills been suspended what's this all
about now is it all about the
territory's leader Carrie lamb having to
resign
well the protesters of course they want
Carolyn to resign because after all
these big protests she didn't really
apologize and she even thanked the
pro-beijing camp for supporting her and
so that's why people are very angry
they're furious about that they want
Carrie Lam to to step down however you
just mentioned that she just announced
that the bill will be suspended and for
most of the protesters a suspension is
not enough they want the bill to be
completely taken off the agenda they
wanted to be withdrawn and so that's why
a lot of people went out yesterday and
today they're still there so the
extradition bill is still very important
so we heard activist Joshua Wong getting
back to Carrie Lam saying she has to go
he's now been released from prison what
do you make of that and what role will
he be playing in these ongoing protests
yeah well he was released from prison
and that's actually just a coincidence
because he served his terms so it's not
like after all these big protests Joe
Chuang got released so and he mentioned
that in prison he watched the news and
then he felt very he felt very said that
he couldn't be with the people
so he also announced that he will join
the protests right away
okay those protests out and two million
people out on the streets um how's
Beijing likely to react in the days
ahead
moving forward to the latest
developments in Hong Kong well Beijing
has already said that they will continue
it will continue to support Carrie Lam
the chief executive it says so it's very
unlikely that Carrie Lam will now
announce that what she will step down
however she is really facing a lot of
pressure because two million people went
out onto the streets yesterday and
that's a lot of pressure it is very
clear that people are very discontented
with with her and also some of her
closest allies have already started to
distance themselves from her so
obviously she's facing a lot of pressure
but Beijing just said they were able
continued to support her so probably she
will still be able to stay in power for
a while thanks Wendy thanks so much for
those insights